[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Хоча ніби скрипкова майстерність
для України не є традиційною,
але в Україні завжди працювало
дуже багато скрипкових майстрів.
[Буковина,
місто Чернівці]
Я не дуже люблю таке аматорство:
«Ну а що, ви не можете гітару підремонтувати?».
Це інший інструментарій.
Оскільки я навчався в Кремоні
і працюю повністю за італійською моделлю,
бачите, працюю по внутрішній формі.
У мене в майстерні крім пилки, жодних пристосувань чи інструментів немає.
[Володимир Солоджук
Скрипковий майстер]
Бо це ще стара, ще трьохсотрічної давності,
технологія виготовлення музичних інструментів.
Зараз багато хто ще примудряється
трошки технологізувати процес,
але втрачається контакт з деревом.
Тому що інструменти надають шум.
Все було би просто,
якби треба було просто вирізати.
А це не вирізати треба, а вистроювати.
Щоб коли ти її зробив —
вона таки мала звук.
Є дуже багато в Україні моїх інструментів.
Звісно, найбільше у Львові.
А так, узагалі — по всьому світу.
Я лише в дитинстві закінчив музичну школу.
І в мене вища економічна і технічна освіти.
Працював на заводі.
Поки завод помирав 1991 року —
я пішов на роботу в Чернівецьку філармонію.
Уже 27 років я настроюю всі концерти,
які проходять в Чернівцях.
Настроюю фортепіано й орган.
А до скрипки прийшов як самоук спочатку.
Хтось приходив смичок поремонтувати,
ще щось зі скрипкою, а потім зацікавило.
Я додзвонився до знайомого майстра зі Львова
і він мені дав телефон
Олександра Крилова з Кремони.
Кажу, я майстер з України, хотів би у вас повчитися.
Він каже: «Добре, приїжджай».
«А скільки ви візьмете з мене за науку?»
А він каже:
«Як з колишнього земляка — нічого».
Виявляється, нічого —
це не просто так нічого.
Є така давня традиція серед скрипкових майстрів:
майстри ніколи не брали плату за навчання.
Учень, який вчиться в майстра,
сам неспроможний продати свій інструмент.
Бо він — ніхто і ім'я йому — Ніяк.
Вже згодом, з роботами —
твоя популярність може вирости,
або, навпаки — знищитись.
Самоуком досягнути дуже багато речей не можна.
Хоча я зробив десь 10-12 інструментів до того,
як приїхав до Кремона.
Але то не становило і 5% з тих знань,
які можна отримати в Кремоні.
Заготовлення деревини —
це повністю окремий процес.
Наше карпатське дерево, особливо ялина —
найкраще у світі!
Після того, як я навчався, я дуже багато років
купував дерево тільки в Італії.
У Кремоні у цього Джабата Морассі,
він з Боснії возить клен і альпійську ялинку.
Він мені каже: «Володю, а де ти живеш?
Покажи мені на карті».
Я кажу — тут, а він каже:
«А ти знаєш, що є такі гіпотези,
що Страдіварі саме у вас брав дерево?..
Подивись, у вас має бути дуже добра ялина».
Чому ялина? Бо вона найшвидше
за будь-який матеріал проводить звукову хвилю.
Якщо взяти гіпотетично кілометрову паличку ялини,
тут стукнути, то на тому кінці
звук найшвидше дійде.
Ми ж усе повирубували,
а потім гори почали сунутись,
почались повені і треба було швидко
чимось засаджувати.
Засадили іспанською смерекою
і вже корінні гуцули думають,
що смерека — то най-най карпатське дерево.
Ні, це не є карпатське,
карпатська — ялина.
У нас її ріжуть і продають кругляками,
як ми бачимо.
Ви знаєте, отакий шматок дерева в Кремоні,
в Італії коштує щонайменше15-20 євро.
Ось цей шматок.
От уявіть собі, а ми кругляки продаємо.
Шукають секрет лаку Страдіварі,
а секрет — дуже простий.
Лак упродовж років не повинен бути
твердішим чи м'якшим за дерево.
Ось і весь секрет.
Найперший інструмент —
повинен бути верстак.
Він повинен бути важкий,
не має мати ніяких рухів.
І стамески.
Бажання і музиканти.
Які би грали на тих інструментах.
Мені пощастило саме жити
серед скрипкових майстрів.
Мені колись мій майстер Саша Крилов сказав:
«Володю, є дві категорії: ти можеш бути
або майстром, або не майстром.
Не першим хлопцем на селі, як кажуть,
а майстром або не майстром.
Бо якщо ти майстер,
то тобі не важливо, де ти живеш:
чи в Парижі, чи в Чернівцях,
чи в якомусь глухому селі.
Ти майстер, і не дивися на суму,
яку тобі платять за інструменти.
Бо сьогодні тобі не платять,
а завтра прийде людина,
яка хоче замовити дійсно хорошу річ
і буде спроможна тобі заплатити,
але ти не спроможний її зробити».
Розумієте, кожен свій інструмент
потрібно робити як останній,
бо ніхто ніколи не запитає
за скільки ти його продав.
Завше будуть знати, що це твій інструмент
і він вартий тільки того, чого вартий.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Олег Сологуб, Михайло Слободян]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Анна Воробйова]
[Музика
Денис Швець]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]